this is a country in crisis
Venezuelans were the richest people in
Latin America now they're being ruined
there are shortages of everything 90% of
people cannot afford to eat millions
have fled the country
and the murder rate is soaring this is
Venezuela anyone who challenges the
regime risks being jailed or even killed
there were more than 300 political
prisoners this man was wanted if we
pursue a political interval by muharram
media pressure for open our port in
Venezuela bananas and Aleppo
[Music]
Antonio Ledezma is a Venezuelan
opposition politician he was mayor of
Caracas for seven years he is an
outspoken critic of Venezuela's current
President Nicolas Maduro the city under
Venezuela catastrophic the boot Elita he
people then put the Reta economic or
social put without monetary with Ramos
field they love me your name is Milan of
Italy Italian territory national no even
seen okay so very moving
Yemen is villa in general whatever ambry
where apple provided William hand of the
lamp
yes reporter in El Pais my freaking
petroleum and mundo Venezuela has the
largest proven oil reserves in the world
the country's former President Hugo
Chavez has been generously when global
oil prices were booming after mr. Chavez
died in 2013 oil prices crashed and
Venezuela's new president Nicolas Maduro
inherited an economic crisis which he
made worse through his ineptness the
country plunged into chaos democracy in
Venezuela
Mihrimah una narco League table nor
ependymoma lethality novela the animal
that told in you in 2014 mister Ledesma
and two other opposition party leaders
launched a political campaign to force
mr. murderers resignation through street
protests normal applause amberyan Della
Rocca
Amelia Lily purposely mahogany from our
Indonesian Camino Anita Karenina more la
salida it for him at all you feel numero
imperfecta in parliamentary regime used
force to crush the protests killing a
number of demonstrators mister Ledesma
was accused of plotting a coup against
the regime the policy a poorly because
of a human
minyul annalisa Carowinds were warned in
India a few names upon current living on
a lot of a like a little mini diver that
I'm aware of it under mr. Maduro the
situation in Venezuela has worsened
lawlessness hyperinflation power cuts
and shortages of food and medicine of
course the continents newest refugee
crisis as people flee in despair this
year alone there have been around seven
and a half thousand anti-government
protests in Ibrahim in calorie and mass
moogle avid Parramatta Lovato
volcana marry Venky Maharaja see in
Decorah Lau Savano Maha Shiva as the
economic and humanitarian crisis has
worsened mr. Maduro has become more
authoritarian the government punishes
senses and intimidates his critics while
under house arrest for almost two years
mr. Ledezma decided to escape have you
planned
Raymond they said without me they suffer
I fear me
record I'm a milky low Metro potala from
Telecom Columbia to the cavalry sharma
my I'm a punto de control military
policy odd assumed en todo lo Viejo
today mister Ledesma lives in exile and
spanked working to bring down mister
materials regime from afar a toy in
portable area for annual international
mental on in Habana Kabul same through
the Opera I only political in May mr.
Maduro won an election that was
internationally condemned as fortunate
and the recent assassination attempt on
mr. Maduro may be a sign of division
within the regime security forces Maduro
alo tacular entrer la solución de Lima
de la coruña II and Commission they will
see close on the Venezuela pornography
dar will not go further away
ee la política they believed our
economic wishes yeah the opposition
hopes that international pressure
further protests and sanctions against
regime leaders will force mr. Maduro to
call free and fair elections but there
is little sign of that working and the
opposition is hopelessly divided as
Venezuela Falls even more deeply into
you
[Music]
you